Володимир Зеленський який стрімко
втрачає електоральну підтримку українців
через провали в економіці скандали з
відмиванням коштів Коломойського та
вагнергейту мегакорупцію на великому
будівництві дістав з шухляди рятівну
пігулку у Зеленського завжди у всьому
винен Порошенко офіс президента зібрав у
Трускавці не лише лояльних слуг з
монобільшості а й кишенькових керівників
силових структур їм поставили завдання
зробити з Порошенка зрадника і
подільника медведчука на швидкоруч
зліпили справу про вугілля з фейків та
брехні фейк перший вугілля від
терористів Україна восени 2014 року в
розпал енергетичної кризи віолевих
відключень аномальної холодної погоди та
блокади Росії ухвалила рішення купувати
антрацит на державних шахтах які були
зареєстровані на підконтрольній
території ц ДП шахта імені Кисельова і
ДП Луганськ вугілля ці підприємства
платили податки в бюджет України а
шахтарі мали змогу отримувати зарплати
та годувати свої родини українські
державні
підприємства які опинилися на окупованій
території але там
збереглося керівництво яке призначено
державою
Україно відкривають на підконтрольній
території
рахунки і отримують кошти за вугілля яке
вони постачають причому часто густо без
попереднь оплати а спочатку поставте
потім з вами розрахуються і
е
забезпечують виручку від цього для
виплати заробітної плати Шахтаря фейк
другий зрив поставки вугілля з
південноафриканської республіки вугілля
з Південної Африки яке купувала Україна
Опинившись перед енергетичною загрозою
за даними експертів немало потрібної
якості і постачалось за завищеною ціною
після втечі Януковича на рахунках
держказничей було 108 000 грн Україна не
могла собі дозволити витрачати зайві
гроші на неякісне вугілля яке просто
погано горіло антрацит з Донбасу мав
нижчу ціну і набагато вищі показники
енергоефективності воно було звичним для
українських ТЕС проблеми нестачі
антрациту і невідповідності вугілля з
пар у 2014 широко висвітлювались у ЗМІ
джерел для закупівлі енергоресурсів було
небагато або Росія або українські шахти
вордло або дорогий невий гідний та
ненадійний імпорт тому на засіданні РНБО
4 листопада 2014 року було ухвалене
рішення щодо перегляду контрактів на
закупівлю вугілля спар і забезпечення
генерації вітчизняним вугіллям
паралельно для забезпечення
енергонезалежності влада на чолі з
Порошенком ухвалила рішення переводити
електростанції з антрациту на газове
вугілля не йде мова про закупівлю
терористів
це вугілля яке належить Україні яке
знаходиться на ее українських шахтах
тому в принципі цим Також ми займаємось
як тільки появиться можливість вивозити
його через дебальцеви з своїми
технічними складнощами ну через стан так
Я впевнений що проблема з буде
вирішуватись
фейк третій змова З терористами
українська влада після початку
російської агресії на Донбасі намагалась
втримати економічні зв'язки з
громадянами тимчасово окупованих
територій цю політику підтримували і
міжна родні партнери зокрема посольство
США виступало проти економічної блокади
державні підприємства залишалися
островами українського впливу на
тимчасово окупованих територіях однак
підконтрольні олігарху коломойському
угрупування під керівництвом семена
семенченка спровокували блокаду ордло
внаслідок їхніх дій підприємства на
території ордло перейшли під контроль
наближеного до Януковича олігарха
курченка на совістьі якщо вона є можливо
її
немає організаторів А я вважаю що
організатори блокади організатори мають
абсолютно безпосереднє відношення до
спецслужб Російської
Федерації
100% всіх наших копалин підприємств які
платили податки в Україну
100% зараз працюють на бюджет
країниагресора і Це ваша заслуга
персональна фейк четвертий плівки бігуса
вугільна справа проти Порошенка зліплена
на основі так званих плівок бігуса ці
записи невідомого походження видають за
головні докази у справі на плівках немає
голосу Порошенка більше того Порошенко
вимагає через суд від Дениса бігуса
оприлюднити оригінали записів як
суспільно важливу інформацію однак бігус
Ухиляється від цього Чому Тому що плівки
бігоса не мають жодного відношення до
Порошенка вони були вкинуті в
інформаційний простір за вказівкою офісу
Зеленського для того щоб Порошенка
пов'язати у спільній свідомості із
Медведчук
це відомий прийом КГБ який називається
тухлий оселедець пропагандисти вигадують
неймовірну брехню про людину і поширюють
її доти доки сморід тухлої інформації не
в'їдається в образ людини
жодна українська спецслужба жодний жодна
силова установа України не взяла на себе
авторствацих плівок ніхто не сказав що
це ми провели в межах чинного
законодавства от це наш результат ми
вважаємо що суспільство повинно знати ні
Навпаки це знову знаєте такі аноніми які
тиражують цю інформацію а Фактично це
прес-служба офісу президента розганяє на
різних сайтах на різних носіях
інформацію яку вони самі і коментують
фейк п'ятий торгівля на крові Зеленський
намагається звинуватити Порошенка у тому
у чому винен сам це Квартал 95 виступав
перед терористами в Горлівці коли там
катували і вбивали українського патріота
Володимира рибака це Зеленський виводив
кошти вкрадені у вкладникі ПриватБанку
коломойським через свої офшори це
Зеленський продає свої серіали та фільми
в Росію це його структура отримувала
фінансування з російського бюджету під
час війни це Зеленський платить
комуналку за квартиру в окупованому
Криму І досі Зеленський отримує роялті
за продукцію яка продається в Росію але
в суспільства є запитання до пана
Зеленського Перше чи були сплачені
податки 40 млн доларів які були виведені
в офшори друге за що саме були заплаче
це 40 млн доларів і третя походження цих
коштів чи мали вони відношення до
привату куди потім з платників податків
усіх було виведено 166 млрд
[музика]
рефінансу